[Música]
las fuerzas prorusas anunciaron el fin
de la evacuación de civiles en la ciudad
de gerson ante el avance del ejército de
Ucrania que busca recuperar esta urbe
ese eventual enfrentamiento amenaza con
recrudecer el conflicto
nuevas elecciones en Irlanda del Norte
nacionalistas y unionistas fracasaron en
su intento de formar gobierno y habrá un
llamado a las urnas en las próximas 12
semanas tenemos el reporte desde Londres
Brasil será escenario de un debate
crucial el presidente Yair bolsonaro y
su rival Luci nació en Lula da Silva se
miden este viernes en el último debate a
menos de 48 horas de la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales tenemos
análisis
actualizamos la información aquí en la
pantalla de 24 Gracias por continuar con
nuestra señal Mi nombre es Juan pupiales
damos inicio con lo más reciente sobre
la guerra en Ucrania las fuerzas
prorrusas en la ciudad de gerson
anunciaron el fin de la evacuación de
civiles ante el avance de las tropas
ucranianas que buscan retomar un punto
clave que fue una de las primeras zonas
urbanas que perdieron desde el comienzo
del conflicto hace ya ocho meses con una
población de unas 288 mil personas las
autoridades en esta zona aseguran haber
evacuado al menos 70.000 en la última
semana expresan que la ciudad es una
fortaleza mientras Ucrania intenta
rodear gerson por el sur y dicen que la
salida de civiles continúa Mientras
tanto autoridades ucranianas aseguran
que en los últimos dos días habrían
derribado hasta 300 drones rusos Aunque
afirman que este tipo de ataques se ha
reducido escuchemos
desde el 13 de septiembre cuando el
primer dron kamikaze jagger 136 fue
derribado en cupians hasta hoy tenemos
más de 300 drones
kamikazeth 136 derribados por supuesto
también está el mojaje posiblemente
otros drones de menor calibre que
también están siendo derribados Pero
estos son los resultados porque ahora
los rusos los usan con menos frecuencia
mientras que antes los usaban todos los
días es porque los drones estaban
disponibles entonces
[Música]
cambiamos de tema en Reino Unido habrá
nuevas elecciones en Irlanda del Norte
que se mantiene en un punto muerto desde
los comicios de febrero ni los
unionistas ni los nacionalistas han
conseguido sacar adelante un ejecutivo y
este viernes el gobierno de Londres
anunció un llamado a las urnas dentro de
las próximas 12 semanas le preguntamos
previamente a nuestra corresponsal en la
capital inglesa Luisa Pulido al respecto
Buenas tardes Sí porque los partidos
como lo mencionabas fracasaron en esta
fecha límite de seis meses para formar
el gobierno probablemente esos nuevos
comicios regionales serán el 15 de
diciembre prestamos a la espera de que
la fecha sea plenamente conformada sin
embargo por la complejidad del asunto es
poco probable que las elecciones sea la
única solución el acuerdo de paz de 1998
que trajo Paz política a Irlanda del
Norte Establece que siempre en esta
región habrá Un gobierno de coalición
entre los republicanos del que arrasaron
por primera vez en la historia en las
elecciones de mayo y los unionistas el
partido unionista
bloquea estas negociaciones desde el
triunfo del chimpan para presionar al
gobierno central en Londres para que
modifique el protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte que mantiene a esta región
británica dentro del sistema de aduanas
el mercado único de la Unión Europea
pero esas modificaciones no dependen del
gobierno central en Londres sino de
Bruselas Es cierto que ha habido
negociaciones entre Londres y Bruselas
con varias polémicas como La amenaza del
gobierno desconocer este protocolo pero
lo cierto es que esta es ahora una tarea
aún más urgente para el Primer Ministro
richizunac la comunidad internacional ya
ha comenzado a reaccionar a la compra de
la red social Twitter por parte del
Magnate y lo Mask considerado como la
persona más rica del planeta desde Rusia
Dimitri subsecretario del Consejo de
Seguridad le deseo buena suerte a más a
la hora de superar el sesgo político
dijo por su parte el ex presidente de
Estados Unidos Donald Trump declaró que
Twitter está en buenas manos y aclaró
que se va a quedar en su red social
desde la Unión Europea llegó una
advertencia Twitter debe cumplir con las
reglas como cualquier otra empresa los
detalles de ese pronunciamiento los
tiene nuestra corresponsal en Bruselas
Ester Herrera
todo el mundo ha seguido con atención
adquisición de Twitter por parte de Long
musk incluida la Unión Europea la
comisión Europea de hecho haya enviado
un mensaje de que las normas europeas se
deberán seguir cumpliendo en particular
el comisario europeo de Mercado interior
terribletón a través de la red social
Twitter ha dejado muy claro que el
pájaro seguirá volando Pero siempre y
cuando se adhiera a las normas
regulatorias europeas en particular se
refiere a una serie de leyes aprobadas
en los últimos meses por parte de la
Unión Europea una de ellas es la ley de
servicios digitales que obliga a las
compañías tecnológicas a retirar
rápidamente el contenido ilegal y
también a tener más transparencia y
Claridad en los algoritmos que utilizan
estas empresas además también se deberá
retirar en esta ley contenido por
ejemplo imágenes y vídeos de personas
que sean de contenido personal y por lo
tanto se deberá retirar también así como
discursos del odio también en campañas
electorales por ejemplo para evitar
casos como el de Cambridge analítica aún
así se va a seguir velando por la
libertad de expresión y también los
derechos fundamentales en cualquier caso
tierra libretón que se reunió con elon
Mask el pasado mayo el multimillonario
le aseguro estar muy a favor de esta ley
y que está en cumplimiento con los
objetivos de la empresa vamos a medio
oriente las protestas en Irán están
lejos de apaciguarse cuando ha pasado
casi mes y medio desde la muerte de la
joven maxam mini quien perdió la vida
bajo custodia de la policía de la moral
al mismo tiempo la represión también
aumenta así como la preocupación de la
comunidad internacional el siguiente
informe nos cuenta las más recientes
reacciones por las violaciones a los
Derechos Humanos por parte del gobierno
en sus esfuerzos por sofocar las
protestas
mujeres lanzando sus velos al aire y
cortándose el cabello en público esta
imagen se ha convertido en el símbolo de
las protestas contra la autoridad en
Irán en otro lugar en la ciudad oc una
multitud grita muerte al dictador
mientras un incendio arde en la oficina
del gobernador local Mientras tanto en
la capital Teherán un mes y medio
después de la muerte de maxamí varios
cientos de personas corean consignas
contra la República islámica las
protestas en todo Irán están lejos de
disminuir y también la represión que en
todo caso se está haciendo más fuerte
según amnistía internacional las fuerzas
de seguridad han matado al menos a ocho
manifestantes Desde el miércoles una
reacción de mano dura que ha provocado
una rápida respuesta de la comunidad
internacional Francia anunciado nuevas
sanciones mientras que Naciones Unidas
ha dicho que ha iniciado investigaciones
independientes
la comunidad internacional tiene
responsabilidad de tomar medidas para
abordar la impunidad por las violaciones
de los Derechos Humanos en Irán y por lo
tanto he pedido el rápido
establecimiento de un mecanismo de
investigación independiente en todas las
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos que
condujeron a la muerte de gi y desde
entonces maxam mini
los manifestantes han sido detenidos en
masa en la represión de lo que el
presidente de Irán Ibrahim raíz y
considera como disturbios Mientras tanto
se inició una investigación sobre
terrorismo luego de un ataque que mató
al menos a 15 personas en un santuario
chiquita en la ciudad de shiraz el
miércoles
asciende al menos 42 la cifra de muertos
que dejan las inundaciones y
deslizamientos de tierra en el sur de
Filipinas mientras docenas permanecen
desaparecidos la mayoría de las víctimas
fueron arrastradas por las aguas o
fueron golpeadas por los escombros en la
provincia de maguindanao son una serie
de lluvias intensas provocadas en gran
parte por la tormenta tropical nalgae
que se espera a golpee la costa este del
país este sábado
en noticias de la región día crucial de
Cara a la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones presidenciales de Brasil de
este domingo este viernes se celebra el
último debate entre el actual mandatario
el ultraderechista Yair bolsonarok quien
Busca la reelección y el izquierdo está
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva para analizar
este tema conectamos con Wagner Iglesias
sociólogo y profesor de la Universidad
de Sao Paulo señor Iglesias Gracias por
estar con nosotros Quién tiene más en
juego en este debate de este viernes
Muy buenas tardes un gusto poder
hablaros con ustedes de
una vez más
este debate de hoy es un debate
absolutamente fundamental en la
principal cadena de televisión de Brasil
que es la red globo va a ser en la noche
de hoy y decenas de millones de personas
van a estar en la audiencia de este
debate Creo yo que es la última
oportunidad para que el presidente del
mandatario en convente jael bolso
intente cambiar el escenario el panorama
porque todas tú estás apuntan para la
victoria por más o menos cinco o seis
puntos de Luis en azul la da Silva y el
próximo domingo sin embargo en la
primera vuelta también las encuestas
apuntaban para un una ventaja una
ventaja muy larga de Lula Pero eso no Se
confirmó Tal vez eso sea resultado de la
distensión o la gente que no comparece a
las sesiones para votar en la primera
vuelta fueron más de 30 millones de
brasileños y brasileñas que no
estuvieron en sus sesiones para votar
esto puede ser un problema para Lula
entonces la elección está más o menos
direccionada para la victoria de Lula
pero vamos a tener la certeza la
certidumbre efectivamente cuando empezar
el conteo de todas las sesiones hoy yo
apostaría que Lula tiene una posibilidad
de 70 a 80% de Victoria en el próximo
domingo
efectivamente Esa primera vuelta
evidenció que la diferencia entre
evolucionario y Lula no es tanta cómo
reaccionó cada candidato a esos
resultados del 12 de octubre para buscar
ahora la victoria en esta segunda vuelta
Lula intentó ampliar su ya amplia su
amplio frente de apoyadores de diversos
partidos e incluso de antiguos
aniversarios
de Centro derecha de Centro
tal vez la más importante el más
importante apoyo a Lula es de el ex
presidente Fernando Enrique Cardozo
nosotros podemos acordarnos que Cardozo
y Lula peleara usted con sus respectivos
partidos durante más o menos 20 años en
Brasil pero ahora están están juntos por
intentar a derrotar a bolsonaro que
comprenden como además que un taller
exista una amenaza a la democracia
brasileña y a la democracia de toda la
América Latina y bolsonarme intentó
trabajar con sus apoyadores
fidelizar aún más sus soldados porque
son verdaderos soldados y que intentan
producir esta
montada Este cambio de escenario por
sonaron no logró hablar para más gente
que no los mismos que ya habían votado
por él en la primera vuelta entonces
este Este es un problema muy complicado
para bolsonar aunque tenga intentado no
logró
apasionar más gente apasionar más
electores para su nombre y para su
candidatura teniendo en cuenta que se
espera que en la segunda vuelta haya
menos votantes En qué tipo de lectores
cree usted que está la clave para
decidir esta votación
yo creo que los pobres la gente pobre la
gente que vive
principalmente en la región noreste de
Brasil en las pequeñas ciudades
gente que vive en las periferias de las
grandes metrópolis esta gente es
fundamental principalmente para Lula si
los muy pobres no van a votar Luna va a
tener problemas porque ahí la diferencia
la distancia entre
el y bolsonaro se va a
se va a tornar mucho más mucho más
chiquita
señor Iglesias Muchas gracias por este
análisis aquí 24 nosotros vamos a
Estados Unidos en un hospital se
encuentra popelos y el esposo de Nancy
pelosi la portavoz de la cámara de
representantes después de que una
persona irrumpiera en su casa de San
Francisco y lo atacara con un martillo
gol de 82 años sufrió heridas en su
cabeza y otras partes del cuerpo de
acuerdo con la agencia ap que también
asegura que el atacante buscaba
específicamente ingresar en esta
residencia según fuentes de la
investigación ancepelo se encontraba en
Washington de si en el momento del
ataque hay un sospechoso detenido y se
espera que Paul se recupere al completo
la fiscalía española retiró este viernes
todas sus acusaciones contra el
futbolista brasileño Neymar y el resto
de acusados Incluyendo a sus padres y al
ex presidente del Barcelona Sandro
Russell el ente acusador considera que
el fondo de inversión dice ha fallado en
sustentar sus señalamientos esta
compañía asegura que fue estafada cuando
el equipo Catalán fichó en 2013 al
delantero desde el Santos por un
traspaso que llegó a los 85 millones de
euros de los cuales dispercibió
solamente 6,8 pese a poseer el 40% de
los derechos del jugador este juicio
termina el lunes y ahora solamente
tendrá la acusación de la empresa contra
Neymar y el resto de los señalados
después de seis años la cantante de
Barbados Rihanna publicó una nueva
canción en solitario se llama Leave me
up y hace parte de la banda sonora de la
segunda parte de la película pantera
negra del universo de Marvel se trata de
un tributo a charlesman el actor que
protagonizó la primera entrega del
largometraje quien falleció de cáncer al
año pasado escuchamos un poco
[Música]
aquí
con Rihanna despedimos esta emisión
informativo ustedes quédense aquí en la
pantalla de France 24 y también en
nuestro sitio web France 24.com
[Música]